كان اختراعه للقاذفه المدفعيه
الاوتوماتيكيه من اهم المنجزات العسكريه
للجيش الاحمر التي اسهمت في نجاح السوفييت
في معارك كبرى كالحرب الفنلنديه والحرب
الوطني العظمى وبعد ان اصبحت له مكانه
كبيره لدى مسؤولي بلاده تحول من بطل يحمل
اسامه الى خائن يرمى بالرصاص
فما قصه يا قبطان مصمم الاسلحه الروسي ولد
يا كوفي
روسيا ويعتقد انه في عام 1900 اضطر الى
ترك المدرسه بعد وفاه والده ليصبح عامله
وفي عام
التحقت تبن باكاديميه اوديسا لتكنولوجيا
الاغذيه
تعرف على طيب فاتن القنابل اليدويه التي
وجد ان بامكان هذه الاداه العسكريه ان
تكون اكثر تطورا
فتجرى واخبر مدربه بذلك ثم تطوع لمهمه
تصميم قنبله اوتوماتيكيه
في خريف عام
1931 انجز تصميما استخدمت فيه قنبله
بندقيه عاديه وارسله الى قياده مدفعيه
الجيش الاحمر التي حولتها بدورها لمصنع
المعدات
لاحقا نقل تبن الى موسكو لمكتب تصميم تابع
لاتحاد الجمهوريه الاشتراكيه حيث طور اول
قاذفه قنابل اليه للمشاهب العالم
كان النموذج الاولي لقاذفه القنابل اي جي
ال عياري 40 فاصله 6 ملم قادرا على اطلاق
رشقات الناريه فرديه بشكل مباشر او بمسار
علوي بمعدل
436 طلقه في الدقيقه ومدى 1250 مترا كما
تم تثبيت القادثه على حامل ثلاثي القوائم
قبل ان يستبدل لاحقا بقاذفه موشاه خفيفه
على عجلات
اصبحت ابن مصمما عسكريا ذا قيمه يزوره
كبار المسؤولين بالاتحاد السوفيتي كما حظي
بدعم النائب الاول لمفوض الدفاع ميخائيل
تخرجسكي الذي كان خبيرا عسكريا داعما
لاصلاح القوات المسلحه لكنه قتل عام
وترك مكانه لخدمه
الذي تولى لاحقا رئاسه مديريه المدفعيه في
الجيش الاحمر
وانتقد بشده جميع مشروعات سلفه بما في ذلك
استخدم نظام المدفعيه الخاصه بشكل فعال في
الحرب السوفيتيه الفنلنديه وتم انتاجه
كميه جيده منه للاسطول العسكري لكن العمل
عليه توقف بسبب الاداره الجديده
بفضل تصميمه العديد من المشروعات العسكريه
حصلت من على وسام لينا لتطوير اسلحه جديده
التي كان من بينها مدفع طائره سكس ام بي
عياره 23 ملم ومدفعوا الطيران 37 ان اس
الذي لعب دورا اساسيا خلال الحرب الوطني
العظمى
رغم منجزاته اتهم توبن بانه لم يكمل مهمته
في الوقت المحدد وبالتخطيط لانتاج اسلحه
غير مكتمله تقنيا وغير مرضيه و تم اطلاق
النار عليه دون محاكمه في عام
وحيث روميه جثته دفن مفهوم قذفه القنابل
الاليه الى ان استخدم الامريكيون قذفه
القنابل الاتوماتيكيه في الحرب الفيتناميه
حينها قرر السفيانيت اعاده الاختراع الى
الانتاج بعد نحو 25 عاما من انكار جهد
توبن ووضعي منجزاته على الارض